welcome to this clemency q a we are
joined by writer director chenoya
chukwua
welcome and the star of clemency alfred
woodhard
thank you very much for joining us today
thank you for having us how are you both
and where are you in the world
i am in los angeles california
and alfred i'm in toronto
so i know i just arrived in toronto i
was in l.a
for the past eight months which is the
longest i've ever been
at home in my entire life even growing
up
how does it feel being in canada it
feels safe
we won't talk about the events of last
night that happened in the u.s and
instead we will talk about this
phenomenal film that you have all
created
chinoya clemency it is um
it's a masterful depiction of a world
that i don't think i've ever
got to see in that way before um can you
talk about how the film came about
please
yeah so um i
was inspired to write this story
soon after a black man named troy davis
was executed
in georgia here in the states and
he was executed in september 2001
and leading up to his execution there
were hundreds of thousands of people
around the world who were protesting
against his execution
including a handful of retired wardens
and directors of corrections
so that really helped galvanize me
politically and really kind of
um instigated my curiosity in
the death penalty capital punishment and
prison industrial complex things that i
never really thought about at that time
and so um when there were those handful
of wardens
were pleading with the governor to grant
troy davis who's the man who was on
death row
um clemency based on the grounds of not
just
um troy's potential innocence but they
spoke to the emotional and psychological
consequences
they knew from first-hand experience
killing troy would have
on those sanctioned to do so and
he troy was still executed many people
around the world including myself were
sad and frustrated and angry and all of
these complexities of emotions but
i kept thinking about those wardens and
directors of corrections
and the emotional and psychological
consequences they were speaking
about and so i just really had a
question
you know what must it be like for your
livelihood
to be tied to the taking of human life
and i just became really obsessed with
that question
and at that time in 2001 i i didn't i
didn't know the difference between a
prison or a jail i did i'd never been in
one i didn't even know what a warden did
like i remember the first thing i did as
part of my research i googled like
what does a warden do um and so
i did the deepest dive
into not just researching
this world and the the practice of
capital punishment in america
but i really committed my life to years
of advocating for people who are
incarcerated particularly those who are
on death row
it really shows in the film you kind of
have built this ecosystem
of like a world that exists as part of
kind of the world that we all live in
but a world that is just
obviously enclosed off and you know
as not a civilian doesn't usually get to
be a part of unless you work within it
so coming at it from that warden point
of view
um was that always the kind of angle
that you wanted to
you know look at and go from or was
there ever a temptation to kind of you
know
make it more about kind of the prison
experience as a whole
yeah from the very beginning i knew i
wanted to tell the story from the
perspective of the warden
i just thought that that we've never
seen that perspective before
and it's that it was such a unique i
thought it would be such a unique
entryway
into this space of a prison and into
what what what better way to um
interrogate this system than through the
gaze of a perpetrator of it
and i just thought that that kind of um
that that complexity would be
fascinating and
and ripe with conflict and in terms of
the research process we've explained
obviously
four years um how
easy or difficult was it to get access
to kind of
within that prison system i imagine you
know there's lots of things tied up in
legislation it's not something that's
easy to penetrate at all how did you
manage to kind of
break that all away so you can go inside
well after doing about a year of
secondary research of just doing a lot
of reading and
interviewing a lot of people who worked
in the or worked in that system
and talking with a few men who were
incar who exonerated from death row
i was living in new york city at the
time i realized that i needed to live in
a death penalty state
and so um i had i've been a film
professor where i taught screenwriting
and directing for years
and so i took a professor position
in ohio that was going to pay my bills
as i volunteered full-time with a
non-profit organization that provides
free legal counseling
for people who are incarcerated and they
at the time
were um they've been working on one
clemency case in particular for a woman
named tyra patterson
so i sent the executive director a cold
email like
he they didn't he didn't know me at all
i did not know them i said listen
these are my skill sets i mean this
genuinely
i want to offer whatever skills i have
for free i just want to help and be a
part of the work that you're doing
and i don't i think i don't think they
believe me at first but
um but then i got on board and that was
my entryway working on tyra's case with
her team
um for about a year and then as i looked
around
um the prison the women's prison she was
she was incarcerated in and
started talking to some of the other
women who were incarcerated i realized
that
um many of the women's stories would
never leave prison walls
so i thought about the work that i have
been doing for years as a professor
um teaching students to tell their how
to tell their story cinematically
and i thought to myself my
ability to teach people how to tell
their story shouldn't be confined
to the to the privileged walls of a
college classroom so i really condensed
my screenwriting and directing
curriculums
into a one-year program that i created
and
began teaching in that same women's
prison where tyra was incarcerated in
and because i had already spent about a
year um working on tyra's case and
visiting her a lot and talking to her
co-defendants
the people the prison staff already knew
me and so
and they we already were establishing a
level of rapport
and so when i presented the warden at
that prison with my idea for this
film program to teach women who were
incarcerated there how to make their own
short films from script to screen
she really jumped at the chance and she
gave me access and i mean i had to put a
proposal together and
you know i mean ev everything was
closely monitored but
i mean i i spent a few years teaching
and working and with with women
who were there and and that and it was a
really successful program
um and got a lot of public attention
that helped
to calm fears or anxieties of prison
staff
when it comes to you know letting me
come into the prison
well that's incredible like a filmmaker
kind of
you know in reverse kind of you know
kind of
working kind of the research angle and
also
the idea of um really kind of giving
back to the topic that you
want to show on screen um alfred
playing bernadine um
i don't think i've ever seen such kind
of internalized emotion um
in someone's portrayal of kind of this
person this human being and their kind
of
livelihood that we've never seen i
haven't on screen before someone that
kind of who lives between life and death
um and has to navigate that and also
kind of
has lost faith in their work and in
their personal life
if you can remember all the way back
when you first read the script what were
your initial thoughts about the
character
well
listening to chinoy you see why i
just ran towards a chance to work with
her because
because she she is
that person that smart people wise
and also cinematically um
i like to work with people who are
grounded in this the subjects that
they're bringing
forward and i don't know anybody with
that kind of commitment that has
has committed their the culture
uh of their lives towards the story they
wanted to tell
um i didn't know there were women
wardens uh so when bronwyn cornelius
is our she put us together
she she met both of us she knew us and
she wanted to
uh she wanted to bring forward women's
stories and so she thought we were a
good match and of course she was right
uh she's a producer of the film yes
yes and but the first thing i
i asked was a you know i was gonna
read and they she said it was about a
prison warden and
and i said okay well what what
what role am i going to read for she
said you're the warden i said
i i would be the warden so so of course
your ears prick up because
you know as as an actor you always are
looking for
a new way to express yourself a new
a new a new muscle to flex
or to develop if you don't have it and
so
not only did i learn that um there were
prison
wardens i learned that they came from
all
from different um disciplines
professionally you know you would think
well
what little girl thinks you know what i
want to do when i
grow up i want to be a death row warden
you know is what kind of
girl would that be well i discovered
because genoya took me on a prison tour
of ohio
we can tell you about that later but uh
that the women i met were much more
calm much more balanced
and in control in a very easy and
naturalistic way
than a lot of people that i meet in my
daily walk
so it was it was a new
it was a new arena and i i love to
i love to learn things not just about
uh protocol which there was a lot of
protocol to learn
in this but i like to
i like to have to um see out of somebody
else's eyes
especially if i don't share their point
of view um
because it's always wonderful to
to to dispel ignorance to
to grasp something new so i knew i
wasn't going to come out
the same on the other end of this
project you talk kind of about the
balance and calm that some of those
wardens have but at the same time with
bernadine
does obviously have that balance and
that calmness but there's such a
fragility to her
that kind of you know the years of doing
this
is somehow you know it's beating her
down and away and kind of did you
find that with the women that you had
met that you and you'd researched it did
and what did you and i'd love to hear
about you mentioned that you'd been to
visited prisons together kind of i'd
love to hear a little bit about kind of
who you met there and kind of what
how that fed into the development of the
film
you know the task that chinoya gave
me was that we meet our warden
at at a critical moment i didn't meet
the wardens we saw we met probably
in that trip um maybe about
three wardens a deputy warden
the director of corrections and
a man who who has probably overseen
the executions of more people than
anyone in the world because he was
uh working at some of the
sort of hottest states that were that
were carrying out state executions
and uh those women were collected they
collected they they would be in our book
club
they would be at our church or our
temple or where
you know what our social club and
you know we would be the ones just sort
of like
emotional and reactive but
they come to it from either mental
health public
health uh they come to that
from uh social work so it's people who
are used to dealing with people
uh in trauma or so
you know as long as you have that prison
industrial complex
until we change that you would rather
have those people involved than someone
who
came just out of the muscle of law
enforcement
um and and and so because you have to
keep
you know like she says i have
you know 2 000 bodies souls to keep safe
in here
so that's why i don't bend the rules uh
you know so learning that uh
a lot of times the tough call
is uh is does not appear to be the most
compassionate one the way that we think
so um chanel you take it from there
i i mean i think that you said it all
i don't know what to do i think she said
it all if we're talk kind of that what
you said was interesting in terms of
kind of the muscle of law enforcement
so many um films that i've seen
kind of based in the prisons here in the
us really do
feel kind of that violent muscle of
law enforcement um but with this you
kind of have obviously
turned it so you see the humanity of it
and that that struggle as well
and what is so unusual is and i loved it
so sparse
as well you know in terms of usually
kind of we
have those kind of prisoner interactions
or you know
the staff interactions but the
sparseness of it
really makes you kind of hone in on
the heart of what you're trying to get
at and i just want to talk to
you about kind of the the directing of
the sparseness and kind of maybe the
difficulty in having that that much
space
it allows the viewer to breathe but i'm
just saying the difficulties kind of
shooting and making it well i
my a main my main directorial
intention was to
[Music]
embody the
industrial sparseness
and starkness of
an actual prison space i think that
um you know often times american
prisons are depicted in screen is very
melodramatic and like
hyper hype
very hyper interpretation of the space
and
that's it yeah and the first the thing
that struck me the most when i
the very first time i entered a prison
was how mundane it was
and it was mundane by design and i
thought
and i and i under understanding the
dehumanizing
that happens in this space i thought
that that made the mundaneness that much
more horrific
and knowing that this systematic process
of killing someone through capital
punishment
was happening and it it just
it it made the the plainness of the
space that much more pronounced
and that is something i really wanted to
capture in the film the
horror is in the emotional detachment
the horror is in the silence
music cannot communicate what the
heartbeat monitor communicates
you know in that opening execution
sequence
the stillness the waiting the
the the manipulation of time and
lengthening time or shortening
all of those are emotional and
psychological realities
of the prison space that i wanted to
recreate
for audiences to experience themselves
and so that was all of those things
informed my directorial choices
in terms of the soundscape in terms of
silences in terms of letting the camera
stay on active so we can experience
their emotional evolutions in real time
in terms of the framing and
compositional strategies and the use of
negative space
and the emptiness in the space um to
mirror the psychological moment of the
characters in that particular scene
and so those are very intentional
choices that i made directorially
yeah the stillness is it's definitely
powerful
in here um we have lots of questions
that have come in
so let's so
we have a question from kevin williams
for alfred
um do you think you could talk through
how you approached that breakdown
scene and sustained it for so long
um
i don't really approach uh
scenes and i don't i used i
i don't think of scenes in a film when
i'm working
i i know the story uh
i have somewhat in my mind
what the script says the dialogue
but what i have charted is
is the intentional journey throughout
the film what what is the intention and
then you lay yourself
open for listening and responding
it just so happened that chinoya which
is one of the reasons i really wanted to
work with her
uh and the cast felt this way she she
assembled a cast that was not afraid of
stillness and silence
because once you
know who your character is and you start
to
to bring that character forward
after action
you are you are
existing living responding in their own
time so
if she keeps a camera on you bernadine
never stops being bernadine
no matter where somebody else in the
room is looking
so you never uh it's it's uh
it works well and it feels like the
music is tonal
when you you you you
you stay you're never acting you're
never doing you're never
uh technically thinking because you've
thought
you've thought through all the
transitions
and you you actually trust yourself
because you've done that
work before you you started to shoot
to be there at the right time and then
your director can say
you know lean a little more left you
know
push you know squeeze that muscle more
so
and to know you'll tell you she had not
planned that
last uh the last hold but she could have
moved that camera anywhere around that
death chamber
and everybody in there
was just being who they were supposed to
be in that moment is this camera falling
anyway um so what you do
is you get out of the way
as we do in all our work i didn't i just
i'm on an iphone it's starting to
do but you do your work and you get out
of the way
bernadine doesn't know anything alfie is
not
present um what's
what's the guy's name heaven
kevin you're not kevin's not present
it's this the reality you believe the
reality that's why you should never get
a film that is not well written
because you got to believe it um and
the thing that that has called on from
us is to
stay focused and you focus by keeping
your breath going
that's you know because that is where
all of our emotions
come from whatever they are that's how
we live so you just keep
living whether anybody says cut or not
i think i think it almost certainly did
you did mention um other members of the
cast and chenoy that is a
beautifully piece together
cast that you've done and kind of how
you've mentioned alfred about
the choreography of each of you around
each other and how you move and react
and i'm
wondering is it was there a lot of
rehearsal
taking place or
you know this was an indie film
all caps indy but you know what the
thing is
if everybody prepares there is no need
to rehearse
if there's a stunt you rehearse but
nobody knows what they're going to say
in life nobody knows what they're going
to do in life so you
prepare yourself you tune that
instrument
and then you show up and you all agree
on
uh you know it's a you know
b flat major and you and you play
the music and the thing is
another thing about chinoya that i so
respect and
is that she recognizes that life happens
in between the lines
doesn't happen on the line and so a lot
of
you know shooting goes i'm talking
you're talking he's talking we're
talking
but how people receive
and then now how they try to start to
come back
that is life it happens in between all
the dialogue but the dialogue is uh
you know of course spot on but um
i don't tell me to know would you have
rehearsed if we had
20 million dollars no
no we talked you know alfred and i
talked for
it was a couple months a few months yeah
beforehand
and aldous and i talked a little bit
richard i was just talking and just
that's really what it is i mean i
alfree is one of our greatest living
actors
and i'll say this and make her blush but
she's one of our greatest living actors
and she
she does the work you know so it's like
it's just
all you need to do is is is have
a strong script and be able to
articulate and talk through
the characters and what's going on
between the words and then
she does her alfred witter thing
he is an actor for that reason and
everybody brought that kind of
professional craft driven energy where
all we really need to do is really talk
about it
and they come having done the work did i
know
i'm gonna i want to say something so we
went on our tour
we went to uh a couple of women's
prisons
uh god there's so many stories we could
tell maximum
men's prison we went to we
had the privilege of meeting with a
couple of condemned men
uh we met with staffs
and inmates um
so i'm gonna tell you it was much easier
to shoot that film
because you're in
the process in the you know your
breathing
than it was to take those tours
because that very thing that you know
was talking about
the the silence the
the mundane days the
the pressure of the nothingness of
waiting of spending time it is
uh it is more horrific than
than all the well i'm saying that i've
never
had endurable beatings and that sort
but um
and people's lives are in the balance in
this story that we're telling
so again once you do that work
once you find the people because all
we're doing ever as
storytellers is bringing the people's
the
bringing the people's lore to them their
history to them
were were
standing up possibility for them so that
so we're constantly working as
storytellers towards the health of
the community the tribe which is now we
recognize a global tribe
ever since we first stood up around the
fire that's what the griot has been
doing
we've got all this equipment there's all
you know there's all of us with
you know there's gaffers and you know
best boys and
you know script supervisors but that's
still what we are
are doing what we're charged to do and
so
i have never been more
seriously uh
charged with telling a story than i was
after
meeting these people who are just like
us when you're in those prisons they're
not there's no criminals in there
that's like your cousin that's your
neighbor that's your uncle that's your
former school teacher that's
it's like people that excuse me they
[ __ ] up
on a bad day and maybe some of them had
the habit of doing that
and maybe some of them fell into it
maybe some of them didn't do anything at
all
but they're not numbers although we give
them a number
and so you find the human beings
and so all after you have experiences
like that all you have to do is show up
keep breathing and stay focused you know
i know a lot of different
roles uh require different things but
again
even if it's even if you're playing a
clown
it is the clowns are sad no i'll just
say even if you're playing
a comedy you prepare sincerely in the
same way
and you show up and all you gotta do is
just
you know you're the instrument you're
not the subject of it
we have a lot of questions let's see
what everyone's asking at home
um erica james is saying as a young
british nigerian creator and filmmaker
chinoya how was your nigerian ancestry
shaped yours how has your nigerian
ancestry shaped you as a person
and as a director and then there's a
second question for alfred
what an honor my question is
um how do you maintain your integrity in
this business
so hello my fellow nigeria
um you know i've been thinking a lot
about this
actually um about
um how so i was i grew up in america
um but i was raised in a very
traditional
nigerian household one of the greatest
gifts my parents
gave me was this unabashed unapologetic
pride
in my nigerian heritage and the blood of
the ebo my evil ancestors that run
through my vein
we went back to nigeria all the time my
parents lived in nigeria they moved back
when i became an adult
and they they're there permanently they
may not come back
and they all we grew up always knowing
that they were gonna go back we came to
america for educational opportunities
um but we went back to nigeria all the
time and
my dad in particular was very adamant
about making sure we understand the
history
of igbo people the history of nigeria
and to connect a sense of pride
to my name chino yeah
i remember my first feature when it
didn't get into sundance i was
devastated and i didn't get out of bed
and my dad being a very african man had
no
compassion
he like taps me on the shoulder and he
was like don't you know you're a chuuku
get up get up you're a choker and
in the moment i was like dang that's
harsh
um but it's an example
of what i mean in the sense that like i
am a chuku and
you know granted i temper we need to
temper that thinking with humanity right
like and compassion but
i grew up with that kind of pride and
that has shaped
me to this day in that i
walk with my head held high i
have a very strong unapologetic sense of
who i
am and what my worth is as a human being
and you know in an industry that
um in a world i guess you could say in a
world that
is very big much based on external
success and people's worth and values
tend to be tied to external success
i think the way that i grew up has
really shown me the value
in people's humanity regardless of
external validation
and seeing my worth you know um
as a human being regardless of external
validation
i'm very proud of my heritage i'm very
proud of that
and it's it's a it's something that i
carry with
carry with me every single day um
every single day so so yeah
your father sounds like my english
problem
what was that alfree make me wish i was
damn
we can we can we can make you an
honorary evil woman
i'm from the tikar people and cameroon
oh i didn't know that and this film did
win the grand jury
prize at sundance didn't it it did
yeah i think you can tell your dad that
you're doing okay
so the lesson in that is you know keep
doing
what you're doing you know the world or
whatever small world it seems to be that
we think is passing judgment
uh you stay true it doesn't matter
that's not a part of your walk
to you know the the walk of an artist is
never too
too pleased but to tell the truth and if
you decide you get the glory of
escorting your talents through this life
uh that's that's the honor that's the
joy
uh but it's a calling it's not a
you know it's not a race or a
competition
the only yardstick is whether you are
off honestly practicing
and are you telling the truth as far as
your horizons have
revealed to you so far
wow
i feel like i'm in a life master class
right now
okay julian alcantara who says firstly
congratulations to both of you for one
of the most moving and powerful pieces
of cinema in recent years
chinoya and alfred um
oh he's he oh so i've got lost in this
question
oh he wants you to talk about the rest
of the marvelous
casting jigsaw and how that was put
together um
and also chinoy did you have people in
mind when you were writing this script
and then i've got a second part question
for alfred but we'll
do that one first uh the cast
the cast okay so the cast uh oh second
part is for me okay got it
uh so after after we
after financing was secure the rest of
the cast happened pretty quickly
um so wendell was attached early on
and and alfred was attached to about two
years before we started
shooting and i knew for
and the person playing anthony he needed
to communicate so much with his eyes
because as you can see in the film he
doesn't speak much
but he says so much non-verbally and so
um i remember bronwyn
our producer um brought up
aldis and i watched some of his work in
underground and there was one particular
episode where his character didn't speak
for like the first
10 minutes of the episode um but he
there was he was doing a lot like there
was a like you know but he didn't
say much and i was captivated and i said
okay well this is our anthony
and then i met aldis and i mean he's
like one of the nicest people that
you'll ever meet in your life
oh my god and working with him was a
dream
and so um and so that was easy and
richard shift i mean the same way where
i mean i loved his work and he just
embodied marty
you know in so many ways and uh we
we talked and hit it off and he really
got the material and
the same thing happened with everybody
else in the cast and it just
worked very quickly and and we were
really
we're i'm just really thankful the
chemistry was there immediately
did you have i think any of them in mind
he asked when you were writing
the script or did you kind of do you
separate the writer director hat
i really try to separate the writer
director hat as much as possible i mean
once after the
first couple drafts once brahman and i
said the name alfree woodard it was like
the choir was singing and the sky
opened up and everything made sense
again
and i said okay well that's our burnaby
and so that was just it um but everybody
else i just
i really look at screenwriting and
directing as two separate art forms
and so when i am writing a script i
really am just my priority is to tell a
damn good story
and um you know sometimes obviously you
can't help that and you obviously think
about
people or whatever and things like that
but i really was focused on let me get
the story right
well you talk about the chemistry
between enhancement but yeah but
alfred and with you and aldous that kind
of
on-screen chemistry both terrified but
of completely different
things but you can just see kind of that
when you're communicating and you're
right you just communicate without
saying a word but it's just all left
there in those spaces in between
the lines incredible yeah the cast
phenomenal and the second part of that
question was for you afraid
um what were the biggest challenges this
character character presented to you
um and how did your act direct your
relationship work to bring
the character from page to screen
help me understand i'm i'm not quite
sure i understand
sorry so yeah what were the biggest
challenges the character presented for
you
is the first part of the question the
second is how did you encounter work
together
from bringing this character alive from
page to screen
uh i think we went to the source
which sort of like you went to you know
it's like a
military deployment we went where it was
and although it was not a physical
battle it was um
it was it was an emotional human
battle that we got to experience
together and it solidified
our sisterhood and it solidified our
trust uh as as uh co-co
creators as artists um
so you know that that it was a bond that
was uh
thankfully thrust upon us
um chinoya
laughs and cackles a lot louder than i
do
sometimes you know like when i'm ready
to work i like to go didn't
take it down and she just like she's
like a joy spring
all the time even while we were shooting
um and talk about an intrepid cast
i mean crew as well because everybody
came on
because of their belief in the project
creatively
and their belief in the humanity of the
project
um so that was about that and
the other part was oh difficulties you
know
i tell you i i don't really have
difficulties
working because
you know and i know a lot of you have
this
you've got skills you've got you're just
sitting there on the benchmark put me in
a coach put me in
because we learn so much more in a
strange way
you know when you're in class and you
want to get up you want to present you
want to be critiqued you're going to
work on something
but what i found you know 50 million
years ago
when i studied was i actually got
as much if not even more i connected the
dots more when i was
watching someone else work and listening
to the critique and
seeing them do adjustments so we all
learn from each other
all the time so we can do you know what
we could do anything all right i'll give
y'all the queen elizabeth
i'm like you know i let all the kates
take the queen elizabeth's
but all of you that were conversing with
i wish i could see
you we're capable of doing any
any of those things because we're primed
for that
so you know we're like a bunch of
olympic
athletes just waiting you know
for for the olympics to come and waiting
for people to have the creative
intelligence
to cast us to to know that there is
nothing that
any of us of any uh persuasion any
ethnicity any language any height
any uh you know whatever
if because of we've taken this calling
seriously we've turned our talents into
a skill
so we can depend on it there's nothing
we can't do
uh so the difficulty
that i find maybe i found early on in my
uh unfoldment as an artist had to do
with me not
trusting me staying out of my own way
me thinking that creativity began and
end with me and i gotta i had to come up
with something it's like no you don't
you have to get out of the way you have
to
you know anyway so that's enough of that
you know the difficulty is your head
it's your mind
being anxious you talking smack to
yourself it's like
if you think about anything else then
your focus is not
in the moment so that's difficult but i
don't do that because
i'll tell you a quick story my son i
used to think say okay there's this
really dramatic scene coming
tell me 20 minutes before i'll go to my
trailer i'll go get the corner somewhere
and i'll prepare or
i don't have to laugh hysterically let
me know in time so i'll get everybody
just bumming me out away from me
but my son you know you want to see your
children i'm a mom
uh they're grown now uh but god i'm
madly in love with them
um he was he was two or three and he
hadn't seen me all day
so we were on extreme close-up and he
and i was like
weeping and talking about something and
he was standing holding my leg
off under the frame and he just in the
middle of me going
but darren you're here mom
you know that's not going he goes don't
cut
mommy's working
and i went back i learned prepare
i didn't have to repair because you know
marva
would still be a marvel alfred could
stop
give duncan his his due and then come
back so
it's all those things that we learn that
you know like you have a fabulous
if you guys are doing a play and you
have a fabulous night and it's like yeah
yeah and then you you know you have some
drinks you go home and you break up and
go
oh hell how can i do it again they're
expecting this of me
well you know what that's beside the
point you start over
and if it happened once it'll happen
again you trust
uh you trust the work you trust yourself
and you trust that
there is no there is no
wrong move if you're working honestly
and creatively
it can be adjusted but there is no
there's no failure
again it's just a masterclass
this is going to be transcribed i'm
going to keep it on my wall
um we have nicolas chern
um who's asking i was aware from the
outset that the lead character was
suffering from ptsd
and this was clearly the main part of
the journey of the film
and how was she to resolve this however
i became more aware of a
strong second theme of retirement and
life challenges as you hit that
retirement
age and the danger of shrinkage um for
the warden and the lawyer and the
teacher
the question um was it always a case the
film would have this second theme
as well or did it emerge as the
characters developed
chinoya were you aware of all these
themes
uh i was aware
because i wrote it yeah but it was
um we had we actually so if the first
a cut of the film the assembly was three
like three hours long like a little more
than three hours long
and so we cut a lot out shockingly
um and the script is not that long but
we caught a lot out and
what i what i what
what became so clear to me in the post
process
was what themes that i wanted
to like once we cut so much out
certain things became much more
pronounced right and so
the the parallels um between characters
with regards to retirement and thinking
about like the next chapter the next
part of their journey
um post post career um
that was something that became that much
more pronounced once we
cut out other things and that was an
unexpected
kind of um that was i mean you know in
post you you
i've when you're as a director i've
always
believed that you know when you're
shooting you are
creating choices or creating options
and then when you're imposed you have to
make you have to make some choices right
and so the film really comes to life in
a whole new way in post and so
those themes that this person who asked
the question mentioned
became that it became so much more clear
to me that
that's at the heart of this film as well
um angela jackson um thank you for such
a powerful and moving film
um she's just wondering has it been
shown to prisoners on death throw yet
and if so how was it received
no um
and i've always i grapple with that
because i don't want to i don't want to
re-traumatize
um there have definitely been i've
definitely consulted
with many people on death row and some
people who've been exonerated from death
row i i remember when i was
writing the script an early draft i sent
an early draft
to a man who was who was recently
exonerated
from death row after being on death row
for 28 years
and it was so triggering for him that he
couldn't talk to me anymore
and i like i respect like i get it and i
just always
think about that moment when it comes to
showing it
um in a death rope is one i don't think
we'll get permission but
two uh i i just don't want to
re-traumatize
you know and i've talked with i've
talked to some people who've been in
prison
for decades um and they're now released
and watched it and
um it's it's hard it's really really
really hard
and so i'm trying to navigate how to be
sensitive around that
i think i don't know i think i just
wanted sorry and
also even when we were shooting i was
saying that
the person i mentioned earlier who had
uh taken or overseen so many executions
he choreographed our executions for us
so they were
they were
people were forced into the experience
of re creating
a death chamber experience and and we
lost a couple of our guys
uh who who were the the
officers strapping down and bringing in
that
triggered and and they couldn't do it um
but we have lots of people in the uh
social work the justice movement
um justice system as well have
over the past year have seen the film
and we've had
you know close to 100 talk backs with
the public people want to discuss it
which is one of the reasons
that we were anxious to tell this story
is to
to open up a part of the conversation
that has never been there people are
used have been pro
or con definitely right now uh the
the majority of americans are against
the death penalty but those states that
still have it
practice it uh you know
vigorously um i just want to i want to
say this because i started thinking
about her
in this woman right now we have to lift
up danielle brooks
she is just you know we we know danielle
has facility but she brought
a vet you know that's the thing that you
did so well
chinoya was that from each person's
point of view you
found that person's way
uh that you found a way of speaking that
person's
truth and danielle uh man she's just
you know there was it was a cast when i
was talking about the olympics before
if you're in a relay and you're going
and all you have to do
you know what trust you lay your hand
out you know they're gonna
put that baton right in the right spot
and it was just
it was that in telling the stories but
it was that
in terms of taking
it was that in terms of taking care of
each other which is what we want to do
all the time
as uh as a cast but sometimes it's more
demanding that we
that we take care of each other
you do you see so much just care on
screen in terms of
the um careful articulation of every
component of the film
just in the the scene that you were just
even talking about afraid
kind of the the horror of kind of the
detail of
execution scene but the careful
articulation of putting that together i
don't think i've seen something
like that before and i kind of yeah i
can truly believe that kind of
the way that you all work together is
like okay is a testament to what we
see on screen there are a couple of last
questions they better be good
let's see
okay so we have tina oboe and she's
saying for trinoya and alfred
when starting off in your career at a
young age
as a writer director and actress what
challenges did you face in the industry
and how did you push yourself to keep on
moving forward to overcome them
um you know i
so i move so i i i would say that i've
been
cultivating my my craft as a
screenwriter and as a director
um for
about 15 years so far i've wanted to be
a filmmaker since i was 13 but i became
really intentional
about my craft um at when i was 20.
i didn't i didn't i don't i don't really
feel like i
entered the industry until
clemency but i made several films
beforehand
where i really cultivated myself as an
artist
and as a human being and then i moved to
la
three years ago and was ready to
really firmly navigate the industry
in the way that i am right now
not for me and this is just for me it is
not i'm not advocating this for anyone
else but for me
not being in the
thick of the industry not
making work
for any kind of industry results or
external
results and really forcing myself to
stay in the work stay in my craft
grow and evolve as an artist
and to have a life outside
of my work so as a professor as an
activist and advocate as a mentor
as a person all
of that has prepared me
for where i'm at now
really beginning my career in the
industry because
i feel so grounded in myself as a person
as a woman and as an artist
i feel prepared to for the
opportunities that are in front of me
right now
some of the challenges that i've
navigated now are
challenges i've navigated in academia as
a black woman
where there are people who expect me to
be a mammy
a mule or their own personal
entertainment
and the moment nine times eight and a
half times out of ten
i'm i'm you know i'm pr i'm pretty
joyous and i laugh really loudly as
alfre said
but those other times is when other
aspects of my humanity come out and i
get tired
or i get you know i'm not happy
or whatnot and i think that you know
mike's what i've experienced as a black
woman
in the world in black women academia and
sometimes the document in this industry
is that when when
not everybody is receptive of me
standing in my power
and i think that the
time i've had outside of the industry to
really
grow in myself as a person and to be
secure
in who i am and to kind of
draw upon the strength of my ancestors
it helps me navigate those obstacles i
face when when i do when i do encounter
people
who are more comfortable with my
submission than my empowerment
and so that has been an interesting
challenge but i
um but i i i think also but
i think i just stay in the work i stay
in the work and i'm
really fiercely protective of my joy
and my energy and sometimes i
i i mean i struggle with depression at
times and i have to work through that
and i got a therapist thank god but
i really i i am good at i'm really good
at
figuring out the tools i need to
um to cultivate my well-being and that
helps me in my
in my professional life yeah i think
especially at this moment in time in the
world of kind of everything that all of
us are going through collectively i
think
it's the most important thing is to look
after your own headspace and your own
well-being
at this point i mean life is too short
i'm just thankful that like the work i'm
doing right now
is really bringing me a lot of joy and
it's not
it doesn't feel like it's taking it away
from it but i
i mean i i have i have a great community
of people i take i turn my phone off at
times i really
i i have mentees who i
continue to talk with and that also
refocuses my energy and reminds me
that there's more to life than you know
there's more to life than the industry
has clemency
um opened up uh
doors for you within the industry or do
you still feel that you have to know
yeah
i mean i mean it completely changed my
life i mean
it completely changed my life um
professionally it expanded possibilities
and like
it created possibilities i didn't even
think about you know
um i think but
one interesting moment last year last
fall that i realized like
we were at the toronto film festival and
um
i don't i don't think i shared this with
you alfred but i was
miserable not because of the festival
the festival was fantastic
and the screening was amazing it was
phenomenal
but i remember one night i was sobbing
in my hotel room i was just
so unhappy and i realized that
my life had changed and there was a part
of me that was
mourning that and i and in that like in
that moment
i was writing um i was writing a script
uh
an adaptation of a memoir called a taste
of power which is about
by elaine brown who's the first and only
female leader of the black panther party
and a big part of her arc as a character
is coming into her own sense of power as
a person
and i realized that i i was so
used to the struggle of of
of an art of the independent of the
artist right and i'm so used to
rejection
and and the uphill climb that i was
uncomfortable with
the moment when i can enjoy the view a
little bit and the moment you know
there's so much more work to be done but
i just
i was more i was more comfortable in
struggle
than i was in success and and there was
something about that moment in toronto
where i realized i have to make a
decision
to stand in my power you know and to
and to allow myself this kind of success
and i was realizing that i was writing
the script um
while i was at toronto and everything
just clicked for me
where um and so i think now
in i'm in the space where i'm thinking
about
okay what what is it that i want what
are what are the new goals that i have
um and to and i'm in the space where i'm
really working to believe that i'm
worthy of those goals
it is it's a surprisingly common human
instinct though kind of
you when you uh so consumed in the
struggle when you finally get
then you can let go of it you don't know
who the new person
you're supposed to be is anymore and
that's kind of the kind of
mourning of it like i thought you know
you've got there but you're like oh
who am i without this yes
yes we have to let it go we have to
allow ourselves to grow and evolve and
yeah oh i've kept you both for so long
i'm so sorry um i think
we um yeah i think we should come to an
end because i have kept you so much
longer than um i should have done i just
worked so
hard quarantining here in the apartment
by myself for the next 14 days i
have so much that i've got to do no
we're
literally in the trenches saving our
democracy over here so
but i still have time for y'all thank
you
somebody pushed the titration button too
hard and the whole thing is going crazy
exploding um thank you so much both of
you thank you for an incredible film
um just for everyone that's in the uk if
you haven't had a chance to see it yet
it is available
on most popular vod platforms so
go out and look at it and it's also
available on theatrical release so if
you can make it to the cinema
and it's safe to do so please do go and
watch it in the cinema
chinoya alfred congratulations and stay
safe
thank you we will you guys be well take
care be well joy